[Music]
[Applause]
oh is manic set to join us
he kind of is all right he's the uh
senior nba writer for sports illustrator
chris mannix back on the program was it
a great day for the nba that the greek
freak is staying in milwaukee
it was a great day for the nba um
a great day for small markets uh a great
day
for the hope that adam silver has
to ultimately establish league-wide
parity
i mean look dan small markets have taken
a pounding
in the last few years whether it's kawhi
leonard in san antonio lebron
anthony davis forcing his way out of new
orleans
you know this wasn't giannis saying all
right i'm gonna give you a
one plus one type extension to to buy a
little bit more time this was janice
saying
i'm all in on the milwaukee bucks i mean
remember
he could have signed this exact same
contract next summer
exact same one but by doing it now he is
showing
uh really endorsing the bucks and
everything they do and i think it's
great for the nba
but what was he thinking about it it
felt like he was contemplating
the possibility of maybe florida uh
maybe texas to play
with the mavs or play with the heat or
like
i'm just trying to figure out what was
he factoring in of whether or not he was
going to stay
or not well from what i understand i
mean
there were a lot of variables not just
going to play
in those areas but the tax ramifications
of playing in florida and texas and look
there were a lot of things to talk about
he had a meeting with ownership
earlier this month that reinforced to
him
that the bucks were not going to be you
know cheap when it comes to payroll i
mean
we've seen teams in recent years skimp a
little bit when it comes to
not wanting to spend deep into luxury
tax bucks ownership assured him
that they would be willing to do that he
had another meeting with john horst who
has been
really masterful dan at assembling this
roster around him and horst assured him
that we're going to continue to look for
talent like they've depleted a lot of
their assets
in the last couple of weeks with that
drew holiday deal but
there still are things the bucks can do
to improve this team around giannis and
giannis heard from management that
they're going to try to do it so
like i think he was just weighing
everything look this is the biggest
decision
you know outside of his personal life
that he's ever going to make he's going
to be
a buck until his early 30s and i think
he just wanted to weigh
every option appropriately give me the
team that
was disappointed slash devastated by the
greek freak staying in milwaukee
oh it starts with miami um i think the
heat really believed
that they had a legitimate shot at
making a run at giannis in 2021
i mean their their best audition for
giannis was what they did to them
to the bucks in the playoffs uh just
this past season i mean they
uh they dismantle milwaukee and i think
that you know certainly showed giannis
that
this was a team that you know he could
step into
a co-star jimmy butler a big man and bam
out of bio that he could win
championships
with for years to come but it wasn't
just limited uh to miami dan i mean you
you could hear the groans in toronto
where the raptors
were certainly preparing for a run at
giannis dallas
another team that wanted a shot at
giannis even the lakers
you know had some some thoughts on being
able to clear enough cap space to sign
giannis
next summer as well so i think there'll
be a ripple effect here
you know like these teams were
protecting their cap space for the
summer of 2021.
now that they don't have to do that i
think we might see more activity on the
trade market
we're approaching the start of the nba
season aside from milwaukee who had the
best offseason in your opinion
after watching brooklyn play in its
pre-season opener
i'm going to say brooklyn and they
didn't do much because they just got
kevin durant back and
you know brought the band back together
but i watched kevin durant dan and this
this kind of reinforces
everything i heard over the last few
months
from people that participated in the
scrimmages with durant
or watch the scrimmages i kept hearing
over and over again
that kevin durant was all the way back
that he was
the same player we saw before the
achilles injury and watching him in that
preseason opener
i thought he moved fluidly he had
explosiveness it's only a short burst of
time
playing in a game like that but watching
him i have no reason to believe that
we're not going to see something close
to the old kevin durant and if we see
that combined with a healthy kyrie
irving
two guys that are proven playoff
performers it's hard not to look at the
nets as at least being a co-favorite in
the conference
i'm not worried about durant which
sounds strange for a guy who hasn't
played in a year and a half coming off a
kelly surgery
i'm worried about kyrie yeah should i be
yeah yes short answer is yes i mean it's
look there are a lot of parallels to
this version of the nets to the 1819
celtics and not just because kyrie was a
part
of both teams um you've got you know
young guys that
have you know kind of already proven
themselves to a degree they're now being
asked to accept lesser roles
and all the the public comments i'm
hearing
out of brooklyn now dan are comparable
to what i've heard what i heard in
boston in 1819 when these guys said no
we'll
take a secondary role we're fine we just
want to win you know how does kyrie
manage some of that like he has the
point guard is going to have to make
sure
that these guys are involved a bigger
issue though dan at least in the early
on
is you know look the james harden
chatter isn't going to die down the nets
are going to be
a contender for james harden as long as
he's available
much in the same way that boston was for
anthony davis during those last couple
of years so
if the chatter continues to focus on
james harden brooklyn
those players in that locker room are
going to look around and go oh
i mean if you're talking about acquiring
james harden that means i go
that means i'm not part of this and look
we've seen kind of firsthand with the
celtics
uh a year earlier with the lakers when
brandon ingram and those guys were
talked about
in the davis trade that can really
toxify
your locker room so how the star players
on that team kyrie and kevin durant
handle that stuff i think is going to be
a factor
in the success of the nets he's chris
mannix uh senior writer
for sports illustrated what is james
harden's approach here
aside from showing up looking like uh
big man on campus
literally it didn't look great didn't
look great in that uh
preseason debut i mean his approach
and and i think this is going to be his
approach is just keep his head down
keep playing hard and sort of anticipate
that the rockets trade him before the
deadline in march
looks like his head is down in his plate
that's the problem
not touching that one at the moment but
this is he
he certainly isn't in the best of shape
coming into this uh this season but he's
got to go out there and play
he has got to be a active member of this
team he's got to be a good soldier all
those
cliches he's got to do all those things
because if you're a distressed asset
you're just become more difficult to
trade the rockets have made it clear
in conversations they've had with teams
that have inquired that they're not just
gonna dump james harden
like come to them with a massive offer
or else don't come to them at all that's
been their position
chris i haven't heard an offer yet has
somebody made a
tangible offer for james harden where
you say those players are going to
houston in exchange for
harden and whatever else well i i don't
think it's as simple as you know like
here's an email i'll trade you this this
and that there have been broad strokes
conversations
you know with brooklyn there have been
conversations with the philadelphia
76ers i don't know
exactly how far those conversations have
gone but there have been broad strokes
conversations about what it would take
to get james harden that means a core of
young players including a blue chip guy
and basically all the draft picks you
have left in your arsenal that's
what it's going to take from houston's
perspective the question is dan over the
next month and this is the big one
will philadelphia deal ben simmons for
james harden that's the player the
rockets
would would absolutely jump at in a
james hard deal they'll probably want
more there will be some haggling between
both sides
but that's a deal that could come
together relatively quickly if the
sixers
are willing to move off ben simmons
explain give me the download on the
lakers new secret weapon
coming off the bench gordon tucker
he's a good player man he played mostly
the g league last year
and was really effective but always in
the g league you have no idea
what you're gonna get but you know the
last couple of weeks and months
you've heard lebron james speak
glowingly about this kid a guy that can
place versatile plays multiple positions
can shoot the three i mean i think he's
going to be a real factor for the lakers
almost like a found
like found gold with la uh who is badly
in need of rotation players on the back
end of that bench
and he was out of iowa state uh yes
and i i think he's only like 19 maybe
he's now 20.
but i think he just turned 20. yeah he
just turned 20 and look
he's he he's just one of those guys that
you don't see coming
and as i said you saw lebron saw him
coming
for the better part of the last couple
of months after watching him and working
out with them
i mean when you have a versatile guy
that can play a few different positions
and can shoot the three on that lakers
team that is invaluable that is
exactly what you're looking for on a
team that needs versatility
great to see you again chris thanks for
joining us as always
you got it dan that's good
chris mannix there i i almost i forgot
who i was talking to
that's uh chris mannix of sports
illustrator senior nba writer there